the FBI shut down Silk Road the online
drug site they called that a major
victory over drug abuse Silk Road
generated more than a billion dollars in
illegal business the most sophisticated
and extensive criminal Marketplace on
the Internet today because people bought
drugs on the site anonymously Silk Roads
founder had bragged the state is unable
to get its thieving murderous mitts on
it but he slipped up
he accidentally used his real name Ross
Ulbricht on an internet forum and the
state found him
the FBI has arrested the reputed
mastermind of a popular online black
market for drugs then judge Katherine
Forrest said because Silk Road was a
black market of unprecedented scope she
would sentence old brick to life in
prison with no possibility of parole
ever he said mom it's a death sentence
it just takes longer and he's right this
is for all nonviolent charges she and
others say it was unfair to La Crosse up
forever for a non-violent crime but why
should we care who was all brick anyway
you seem nice enough pretty sure I want
to start a family the next five years as
a kid he was a quiet nerd than an Eagle
Scout
excited to go to college but in college
he became a libertarian and he wrote I
want to use economic theory as a means
to abolish the use of coercion coercion
meaning force he viewed laws against
drugs as coercion force that stops
peaceful people from living the way they
want he was right but many Americans
hate and fear drug use you're breaking
up the social fabric of our country they
applauded when the judge announced Ross
would be in jail forever this is a judge
who finally got it right right all right
we all agree here life in prison without
parole
anybody else any other wise guys want to
do it that's what you're gonna get
give me a break prison without parole is
not going to stop the sale of drugs
we should have learned that from
America's attempt to alcohol prohibition
once you're an adult if you want to buy
intoxicants should be your right where
that's legal sales are done without
violence and the products sold are safer
this is your brain on drugs yes many
drugs are dangerous some who bought
drugs and Silk Road died at least six
people died his mother said nonviolent
guy no no no Silk Road had some rules at
least like nothing that harmed or
defrauded no child pornography was
allowed but now that the government's
closed Silk Road replacing the site with
this notice other illegal sites have
opened and they offer more drugs these
other sites I've heard that they're just
open season anything so they're actually
worse and multiple times bigger she'd
actually never seen them so we used the
web browser tour to show them to her
it's not like they got rid of these
things here's another one
and by the way Silk Road had 12,000
listings when it was taken down the new
sites offer more than a hundred thousand
so I guess they weren't scared by Ross's
life sentence as the judge said but law
enforcement keeps bragging about
successes the darknet is not a place to
hide here's Attorney General Sessions
announcing that they'd shut down another
website we will use every tool we have
to stop criminals from exploring
vulnerable people but the shutdown's
hardly make a difference new sites
appear now critics will say as we
shutter one site another site emerges
and they may be right but that is the
nature of criminal work it never goes
away
never ever heroin heroin so they didn't
stop anything no they actually there was
a spike after the sentence was given it
had the opposite effect it's a travesty
what's going on still I find it hard to
support her son since he was also
accused of trying to kill people murder
for hire plot trying to hire a hitman
it's completely digital evidence and
hearsay basically by the government
ohlbrecht suspects an undercover cop
planted those messages a mortgage
company will not take
greenshot of a bank statement because
they know how easily faked it is no one
was actually killed and the government
didn't charge ohlbrecht with
murder-for-hire in his trial but let's
just say for argument's sake that
everything is true the typical sentence
for murder for hire when there's no
murder because there were no murders to
be clear is ten years double life plus
forty years without parole for a young
guy who you know is a zealot he was a
libertarian ain't believed in free
markets and volunteerism he is not a
dangerous person
no American is safer because Ross
Ulbricht is in jail for life he's just
one more casualty of our failing drug
war drug dealers shoot each other
shoot bystanders and corrupt whole
neighborhoods the police risk their
lives and sometimes kill innocent people
locking up Obrecht won't make anything
better the drug war does much more harm
than any drug
you